we got cubans out here
[Applause]
cuba is really my favorite yo i'm not
gonna lie
i love i love okay
i love cubans because uh y'all turn into
conservative republicans immediately
after getting into america
like y'all are refugees
immigrants and the second you get that
dry foot
the second that foot drive you're like
okay any immigration he said no he said
no
hey he said no immigration hey it's too
many people
it's too many people how how hey we need
a system we need law
we need law my foot dry my foot dry
i'm american now feel it feel it touch
it
okay i cannot play domino at the table
there's too many people coming
i cannot play domino how do i play
domino if everybody coming
i'm not like you i'm dry food you went
back that's different that's different
that's different that's different i'm
dry
son cubans cubans you good bro this guy
about to die son
it's true right cubans wearing the maga
hat
cuban said son they just got here
cubans they just got here to make
america great again bro
back to win no we need to make it great
again
like when do you remember it great hey i
seen the movie i seen the movie
i seen the tv show i seen i love lucy
ah cuban was it now it was great back
then
what's up bro [ __ ] aquaman in the
front row darkness
handsome [ __ ] look at him dude
serving tables and dick afterwards
i better watch
hit it dj swallow that
oh man
god bless you [ __ ] latinos man
uh puerto ricans and dominicans just
you're the same we don't care
uh we don't care uh just on behalf of
everybody not latino
saying i know you think you're different
you're not [ __ ] different it's
we're so different no you're not a
different right
no they dance like this we don't like
only reason dominican girls dance like
this because they got stds bro their
cushions burning
it's burning bro
that [ __ ] is oh i need to get checked i
need to get shanked
hello hello latinos
one indian girl in the front i am not
latino that's what she did too
i am not no good
i love let me tell you my latino people
let me tell you something uh first of
all i love the latino people because uh
i'm indian
and we're the we're basically the
latinos of the middle east
when you go there you'll find out don't
rush over anytime soon first of all
i like the spanish that you guys speak
and i specifically say the spanish that
the latinos speak
because i went to spain last year and
that's where they speak the real spanish
uh i don't know if you've ever heard the
real spanish being spoken but it sounds
fruity as hell
ever they speak spanish with a lisp i
didn't know this i get off the plane
this guy's like hola
como esa
i'm like seriously dude this was a long
flight
i don't need this right now i'm sure
you're a nice person i'ma talk to this
guy excuse me
see first time in
barcelona
see
see when i hear latino people speak in
spanish i can i can't understand it but
at least i know when a sentence starts
and when it ends you know what i mean
there's certain languages you have no
clue
whether it was a statement a sentence or
a paragraph right like
like when i hear spanish i can hear you
like
i don't know but yeah
you hear people speaking chinese you
don't know whether they said a word a
sentence a paragraph
sometimes they don't even start the
sentence at the right spot they just
sound like they fade the words right in
you know
that starts
it's almost like they have add because
they'll just you know extend the word
right in the middle of the sentence you
know just
i look away for one second you go crazy
it's funny to me that they speak spanish
with a lisp over there but the latino
people don't because if you think about
it the spanish came to you guys
and made you learn their language but
even your people recognized how fruity
it sounded you know
repeat after me if
[Applause]
ha
[Applause]
why won't you sound like me cause you
sound gay
and when i'm there i'm trying to find
out i'm asking around when i'm in spain
i'm like like how can an
entire country speak with a lisp that
doesn't make any sense to me right like
there's no way they can all have an
oversized tongue
so i asked around this is what they told
me apparently back in the day in spain
there was a king who had a lisp and in
honor of the king
everybody spoke with a lisp and then it
just stuck
i'm like that's the dumbest story i've
ever heard in my life
but then i started thinking about it
maybe that's what happened to my indian
people
maybe we sounded like this and then some
king came along
hello everybody
and everyone's like yo what's up with
the king dude i don't know but just talk
like him so he doesn't feel like a
jackass yes sir can we help you
isn't it funny how one little head
motion can make you look as indian as
like
i could look like i just got off the
boat five minutes ago
do you know why i pulled you over
another one that doesn't speak english
where to go buddy
is no joke i said martinez what is this
like week five now that we've been here
week five for sure yeah yeah a month
about him yeah over a month you guys
hanging out here in florida and uh
but he got crazy the other night he
texted me and he mentioned it earlier
but he uh
he got a little crazy and wound up in
hialeah somewhere at someone's house
[Music]
and for everybody watching at home
highly is no joke it gets crazy over
there all right
if you're white and you're driving
through hialeah after one in the morning
even the gps is like
good luck careful
oh yeah it is the east coast version of
east los angeles yes that's
and of course what's up people asking
you know what are you going to shoot the
next one and i've been talking about
doing stuff here in florida for quite
some time and so i'm really excited
and i actually thought i used to think
that uh the cubans were the number one
latinos here in town i come to find out
that puerto ricans are creeping up
[Applause]
puerto ricans you guys are very easy to
identify most latinos you gotta listen
to the spanish
puerto ricans i give it up you're easy
to identify because there's always a
flag nearby
puerto ricans love the puerto rican flag
and i know why
i know why because no one's looking for
you
you can be as proud as you are
all day long if you don't know the
puerto rican flag it's very easy to
identify it's red white and blue it has
one big star on it
a triangle and uh it's like the american
flag but tweaked
it's like the cuban flag but backwards
in the colors
yeah you guys love that flag you will
put that flag on anything freaking
bumper sticker hat t-shirts wallets a
baby's born
oh yeah you're definitely the most
advantaged of all the latinos
you know because mexicans were you know
we're loud to an extent
but when we realized that there could be
potential drama yeah
but we work hard and i noticed too like
um there's actually a mexican community
here in town i didn't know about
and uh i saw some guys doing
construction and that's when i found out
because
i heard the music playing and it wasn't
like celia cruz or nothing that was
actually freaking you know regular going
on we evolved
you know straight up i was like that's
mexican music and i saw a guy in one of
the scaffoldings and i go you guys are
working over here oh she said you're
senor i go in this economy you guys are
building another house
oh senor these people have a lot of
money mucho dinero
mucho dinero are they rich very rich
how rich senor i'm not even mexican he
pays me to talk like this
all the fast food restaurants latinos
everyone
[Applause]
jack in the box
all latinos
you have to speak spanish to get a
hamburger
i'm sorry guacamole
[Applause]
m is this jack in the box
can i kill you
do you want some shin
[Applause]
i'm high can i have a jumbo jack okay
you want a jumbo jack jumbo yak i don't
i don't think there's a wine jack
i'm sorry
[Applause]
i say do you want to cheers
right
um my friends are fine thanks
and this is how you throw them off what
kind of fat and drinks do you have
excuse me
what kind of fountain drinks do you have
one minute please
[Applause]
what is what it is fountain drink what
is it
what is what is it what it is
what
[Applause]
[Applause]
me something is like i'm a stupid
[Applause]
why not stupid
son of a [ __ ]
we gotta
[Applause]
you want i don't want to talk to the
manager i want something to drink
tello horchata i want a large pepsi
you're like a spray espresso
[Applause]
sprite